it is little over a week since the most
devastating floods ripped through
communities in this stunning corner of
kentucky
i've never seen anything like this
we traveled deep into these appalachian
valleys past rivers that were
overwhelmed
roads out
and homes gone forever have you ever
seen water like this no
no
never and i've lived here my whole life
the people here are not well off and
they lost everything
it took about five minutes for that to
happen five to six minutes and it was
gone
but what about the bigger picture the
cause climate change
possibly yes
in a place called troublesome creek we
met a man called nolan allen
he'd approached us
he'd wanted to show us what the flooding
had looked like
obviously you're scared i've never seen
the water
in my driveway that far
it's unimaginable and do you have a view
about climate change and that debate
well
i could this is coal country
the people
most of my family my friends
people i know went to school with
their livelihoods were coal based
pretty much
and uh
we can't immediately go to any other
form of energy we just we don't have the
capability it's just not as simple as
going green going electric you can't it
is not you cannot
you can't
politics is of course entwined in all of
this
kentucky is a red state climate change
skeptic donald trump won here in 2020
with a whopping 62 percent of the vote
and yet the governor is a democrat
andy beshear won his election by a
whisker thanks to support in the cities
but not so much out here
and so he must walk a fine line
we know we'll still be finding people
sadly in the days to come
he knows how divisive the climate change
issue is three full days after the
floods he hadn't mentioned it until we
asked him listen i believe in climate
change i believe it causes more
devastating weather but my job right now
is to get families back together get a
roof over their head and make sure they
have enough to eat they just want to
find their relatives and they don't want
their experience to be co-opted in a
larger debate
eight hours drive to the east washington
dc the capital of the world's second
biggest polluting nation mr mansion here
that larger debate is front and center
but progress is hard going
remember glasgow when joe biden made
massive commitments to cut carbon
emissions well that was all based on the
cooperation of the people in there and
over the past few months
there has been gridlock the deal that
president biden hopes to sign
is a compromise but it does include
loans for electric cars to cut emissions
and crucially support for states like
kentucky tax credits totaling 30 billion
dollars to encourage domestic
manufacturing of wind turbines solar
panels and batteries
in all the biden administration says it
would slash the country's carbon
emissions by roughly 40 percent by 2030
the promises he made in glasgow within
reach
that's all very well but it's too late
for the people of troublesome creek
whose experiences now seem to be the new
normal
mark stone sky news